4th
place Cheese to set
me
I can get it while it's hot It
's the chief priest It didn't come out at exactly the same time It's
amazingly accurate
but [music] was the ruling party yan
n
ame If I'm not feeling well I won't burn it and I won't go later  The umami must have sprung up afterward,
and it's fundamentally different from the snow mountain anti-poisoning
[music],
but the exchange part is exactly the same skinny,
wealth 5, how much you've been trained.
The taste of a set meal restaurant is definitely no match
And our guys are trained to perfectly reproduce these legs It's because of me What's going on
today
?  I can't get
into the top ranks Contact:
Yukihira, how is it going over the winter?
I'm determined to win